welcome back we just saw the video all
right well I guess it your names I guess
so big we appreciated welcome to my show
no the boss will placate I start going
all over you we saw the video of the
press conference I don't spend a ton of
time on it but this is really really
ridiculous at all step we've been banned
by the way for two years so it's not a
new development
it caught win today because big cat you
and PFT - commenter the PMT boys you're
going to Mike Florida this is NBC and
you got banned right yeah unfair because
other than threatening Roger Goodell's
life sitting in his office handcuffing
yourself to everyone else threatening
his life over and over saying he loves
Isis you ever did anything wrong I think
I think if we actually watch the film
you'll find that we take this serious
and I was within my rights and not only
on the wrong side of law I've been right
every time roll the clip
again as a member of fighting for
freedom seat committee guys this is
America you can't
[Applause]
let me say this that's as close to
somebody who actually had true facts has
ever gotten to Roger Goodell and he had
to hear the Hitler chants this shirt I
actually believe is the truth I don't
want to go into it it's a disaster
allegedly allegedly parity law yes we've
been doing this for two years we've been
paying the do plates but it's all we we
we know can else here talks about
murdering him except for you I don't
talk about murdering him I just said if
it happened not doing that's not the
worst but I say dead serious and this is
a really true statement the fact that
we're banned when media like pro
football calm all the Boston stations
asked me to go on their show and we're
not even allowed as guests that is an
American this is serious voice into the
thing that is against the law that's
unconstitutional and if I fought I'd be
like this is disgusting ever is freedom
of speech why don't you lawyer up yeah
freedom of speech you know what though
you know that chicks love the bad boys
so you kind of love it too I said that
the house that is the best thing that
could ever happen to us he's playing
right into my hands by the way we do
have our own TV TV show and I want to
say this for the record
Roger you're banned from this show so
turn
[Applause]